babies start being racist from the age
of three months old you know they become
aware of different skin colors and they
start showing preferences for the same
skin color as their own anybody with an
ounce of common sense knows that this is
completely ridiculous the idea of babies
being born racist it becomes an almost
religious idea of original sin
british police officers have been told
to embrace the label woke what's going
on
well it's good question because what
they're clearly not being told to do is
go out there and fight crime um they're
being given anti-racism training and
they're being told that if they
um think that this anti-racism training
is going to see them being labeled as
woke then they should just embrace that
and go with it
i mean clearly nobody wants the police
to be racist and suddenly i don't want
the police to be going around targeting
people because of their skin color or
anything like that but i think what most
of us want the police to be doing is
actually catching criminals and catching
criminals irrespective of their skin
color and nobody has a problem with the
police really having training in
anti-racism but the question is what
what kind of training they're getting
and central to this training is is
they're being told basically that any
racial discrepancies uh any kind of
where one uh ethnic group is seen to be
kind of out of proportion to another
ethnic group is a problem
but you can't really go about fighting
crime in that way it means you're
fighting crime with one hand tied behind
your back you you're always looking at
skin colour and you're left thinking
well you know have we stopped in search
too many black people this week have we
perhaps questioned too many
brown skin coloured drivers have we
pulled over too many white people
and you can't you can't release properly
if you've got one mind on skin colour
you've got to be looking at who's
committing the crimes not what color
skin they've got
so it seems to me that this does make
policing woke and the problem with it is
not that they need to embrace it it's
that they need to ask themselves why
they're not busy spending their time
catching criminals rather than messing
about with these things looking at
people's skin color
abimbola johnson chairwoman of the
scrutiny panel
what is this that sounds
terrified chairwoman of the scrutiny
panel that will hold forces to account
over the plan expressed disappointment
that officers refused to say whether
policing was institutionally racist as
they launched the initiative johnson who
was appointed after black lives matter
demonstrations in britain in 2020 said
officers should be comfortable with
being called woke
yeah do you know what that's the classic
catch-22 that woke um tricks people into
and particularly around issues to do
with racism so this big thing like you
know are you going to say that you're
institutionally racist
they can't win on that one so i'm not
surprised they didn't answer it because
if they say you know yes yes we are
institutionally racist then it's like oh
my god what are you doing why are you
institutionally racist we better fire
you all we better recruit a whole load
of new police officers send you on a
load more training sessions you're
clearly doing something very wrong but
if they say no we're not institutionally
racist then by definition of the kind of
woke mantras they are racist because
they're not admitting to all their
innate prejudices so i i think if
anybody asked me that question i would
avoid it too because
like say it's one that you just cannot
win in the eyes of these white people it
is unfalsifiable some of the things that
get put forward you think i'm damned if
i do i'm damned if i don't
and
silence is both violence and compliance
so it's it's not even as if i can't
choose to not innate engage in this
discussion
everything every single different
approach that you could have to that and
disappointment in not agreeing to what
you said that you wanted it to be from
the
scrutiny overlord or whatever she's
called
yeah absolutely and it's like that
classic thing that you used to do when
you were a kid when you tossed a coin
you know a heads i win tails you lose
they can't they've they've completely
stacked all the cards in their favor so
that whatever arguments are put forward
they think they can win so i mean if you
try and challenge this idea that we've
got an institutionally racist society
with statistics if you say actually look
you know you look at what's going on in
education look at who's getting the best
exam results you know look at who's most
disadvantaged in education for example
or you know look at who's going to
university who's getting jobs and point
out that there aren't all these ethnic
or racial disadvantages that people are
making out then they say oh no you can't
just use statistics you've got to talk
about people's lived experiences uh
you've got to talk about you've got to
look at how black people are actually
experiencing racial inequalities and
racial disadvantages
now there might be some some truth in
that you know you you is it i'm not
saying it's never worthwhile to consider
people's lived experiences but the
problem is you see when when some black
people come along and actually they say
do you know what no there isn't all the
racism that you're describing i don't
feel as if i'm at a constant advantage
suddenly you find they're the wrong kind
of black person you know that their
lived experience doesn't count it's only
some people's lived experiences the
people who are saying the right things
the people who are going along with what
these woke scrutiny committees want to
hear it's only their lived experience
that actually counts is it not funny
that the most the the broadest group of
people that seem to be pushing this
aren't part of the racial groups that
they're supposed to be defending
that i mean we saw this in america right
that when the defunder police thing came
around that if you actually surveyed a
lot of black communities that they said
that they wanted more policing because
it was their children that were going to
be injured i had do you know mary
harrington from unheard
yeah so she came on the show and she
told me the story about
um the introduction of the pill in the
1960s
increased the number of number of uh
single mothers and the uh dissolving of
chivalry norms around not hitting women
holding the door open being sort of kind
and gentle and a protector and a
provider that these disproportionately
hurt
women from working-class backgrounds but
they were being pushed by middle-class
women we're emancipating women from the
tyranny of the patriarchy we don't need
to be have the door held open for us so
that men can stare at our behinds as we
walk through and what you actually look
when you when you see the the stats it
suggests that
some women that were in
societies and social classes that maybe
needed more constrained norms in order
to assist men that perhaps didn't have
the same level of education or role
models in terms of what is and is not
acceptable behavior around women they
were the ones that were
disproportionately affected by this
policy that was being pushed by somebody
that never had any idea about what was
going on on the at the cold face so to
speak and it kind of
seems to me that it's similar with
regards to policing
and policies around that that
a lot of the time the policies that are
being pushed forward aren't being pushed
forward by people that are in the
communities that they're actually
affecting and if you ask them they might
not want what is being promoted
definitely and i think the best example
of that is with all the different views
around trans trans activism
um if you look at most transgender
people certainly most transgender people
who i know
they actually just want to have a quiet
life you know they don't want to be a
political footballer they just want to
you know in the classic the words of the
classic kind of jk rowling tweet they
just want to dress however they want and
be left to get on with living their
lives however they see fit same as
everybody else but the number of people
who it seems to me the people who are
like the most vocal transgender
activists are not actually transgender
themselves they're kind of taking it on
board to act on behalf of this community
on behalf of these other people in ways
that actually a lot of transgender
people don't appreciate and don't want
and they've ended up with their entire
kind of life being politicized something
they've not asked for and and this is uh
people who are not transgender who've
done this for them um but you know just
going back to what you're saying in
relation to feminism i mean one of the
things that i really object to with
contemporary feminism is the way that it
it constantly seems to bang on up to
women that they're victims you know that
they're really at a disadvantage and i
think that's what i see a lot in um
critical race theory politics around
race as well nowadays and certainly if i
was um black and the mother of black
kids you know this idea that that the
message goes out that you're at an
inherent disadvantage no matter what you
do um you know the odds are stacked
against you the world's a hostile place
everybody's racist society's just out to
get you it's just like what a message to
give to kids whether that's to give to
black kids gay kids um you know girls
it just seems like the number one thing
of identity politics is telling people
certain groups that they're really at a
big disadvantage in life and and often
like you're saying you know it's not
people who are in those groups
themselves who are doing that it's other
people coming along telling them oh
don't you know everything's going to be
really [ __ ] for you and and i think
that's terrible to tell people that
that's how we raise up the marginalized
we'll raise them up by telling them that
the world is unwinnable i would be
really fascinated for someone to do
um some interviews with interracial
couples so let's say that you had a
white mother or a white father that
you've got some dominant genetics if you
have a a black spouse um your kids are
going to be at the very least darker
than you if not you know very very black
i would love to find out what their
experience
of kind of being thrust into a world
where they're now very invested in um
the messaging around race disparities
minority um
messaging i think that would be
fascinating you know to work out what's
it like to be a mother that maybe has
lived or a father that's lived their
entire life
observing this from the outside to then
be sort of put onto the um
stadium floor
definitely and the thing that worries me
about that is i think
certainly somebody kind of my age we
have this very complacent view so i'm
kind of late 40s now it's very
complacent view that
society gets better you know that that
things are better suddenly it does seem
true to me that the world is a lot less
sexist racist homophobic than when i was
a kid you know think things you think
social society progresses and this
there's progress in in we're more
tolerant we're more liberal nowadays but
my worry is that when you talk about
something like that
that
the the old kind of color blindness that
would have been genuinely progressive
but would have meant that you know if
you married somebody with a different
color skin to you if you had a
mixed-race kid you wouldn't even use
that term mixed race you know it would
just be your kid you know you wouldn't
see your kid in terms of a skin color
you wouldn't see your partner in terms
of a skin color it was just your partner
it was just your kid
whereas i think the really ugly thing
about identity politics is it pushes
people to
see even in like the most intimate
private areas of their life to start
seeing kind of differences different
experiences different skin colors and to
to kind of be walking on eggshells
around these issues which they're told
should be really really sensitive
and like so that that seems a funny kind
of progress to me it actually seems like
a big step backwards what do you mean
when you say the word walk
yeah it's a really really difficult
question and in a way i guess i'm kind
of taking 300 pages of my book to answer
that question
i mean in some ways some people have
heard describe it as a kind of extreme
political correctness but but to me it's
a bit different than that because it's
it's not just about going around saying
what words you can and can't use
although that's a big part of it
it's a kind of complete outlook on
society it's a complete way of viewing
the way the world works particularly in
terms of race and gender those are the
two big issues that really come to the
fore um
but it it's very much about identity and
privileging um different i dividing the
world up dividing people up into
belonging to different identity groups
and then affording different status
different victim status to each of those
different groups so you create they call
it intersectionality you create these
kind of pyramids if you like of
oppression where you've got i guess a
black transgender people at the top and
you've got white men at the bottom and
everything that you are expected to need
to know about a person you're supposed
to be able to gather just from looking
at the color of their skin their gender
their sexuality
and it's horrible you know because it it
really reduces us down to
the most well i often think you know the
most boring facts about us the least
interesting things that that there are
to know about a person but it's also
just really backward in the sense that
it doesn't allow us to see
um the character of somebody to see what
people are good at you know you just
become your biology
essentially and
the case of transgender people not even
that just just kind of some vague
feeling that they might have about
themselves
um
so it kind of pushes us to recognize
identity
it pushes us to think of people as
victims it really combines all these
things but but the worst thing about it
for me is is in doing that it becomes
very authoritarian it kind of tells the
rest of us how we should behave uh how
we should speak how we should react um
based on these characteristics that
people have got isn't it interesting
that the word woke was actually
appropriated itself
yeah
definitely so it was a word i used
originally in in america among black
people in america going way back before
the civil rights era and it was a
warning essentially a warning at a time
when sadly these warnings were really
really needed uh from one black person
to another you know watch out for police
violence watch out for white people
essentially who might be out to get you
at a time when that could be a really um
serious threat you know there were
lynchings and violent mobs racist
violent mobs going on and yeah over the
course of kind of i guess almost 100
years now that word's been taken on
board it's been taken on board first of
all by trendy white people uh
particularly took off over the course of
the black lives matter movement as that
really began to grow um there was a time
around 2016 2017 when it became really
trendy really fashionable you'd see
lists in magazines you know hot woke men
uh wide being woke makes you sexy you
had jack dorsey when he was in charge of
twitter on stage in a t-shirt kind of
saying how woke he was
um you know and and
so people were really pleased and proud
to kind of own this label woke and they
really wanted to show off how virtuous
they were show off their work
credentials but then as soon as people
from the other side started using that
label in response to them and kind of
saying so this is your woke then are you
uh they took an objection to that and
then
since then over the course of the past
five years the words being used as this
kind of political football where it's
either being taken on board by the left
who are very proud of being woke or it's
been used as an insult by the right to
kind of highlight the most extreme
unwacky and horrible ideas that are
associated with it i'm not sure that
anybody on the left even likes to
reflect the word woke cannot be used
unironically
anymore like the only way that you can
do it this is
something that i was so fascinated to
watch you saw this with political
correctness which was maybe what the
late sort of naughts
into the mid-teens and it took a a
little while but then it became oh part
of the pc brigade are you and
you saw
political commentators cultural
commentators comedians start to use pc
as a meme of itself right and then
what you got to see was woke become
used unironically and then within what
felt like days
just completely reversed and used to
satirize the group or the extremes of
the group that were using the word
unironically and i i think that it's
it's an interesting um demonstration of
what
comedians and the use of humor and
ridicule can do online because you could
have tried to mandate that word into or
out of
law or
create some sort of culture around it
that was top down dictated but if you
make a word socially so toxic that no
one dares to use it that's the most
scalable way to bring something into or
take something out of the culture
because
your desire for status and fear of
losing it doesn't matter it's just going
to scale forever and ever and ever and
no one needs to enforce it because the
group will enforce it on your behalf
no i think you're absolutely right and i
think that is a really good example like
you say of the power of of turning words
around and using them back at people but
it's really interesting at the moment i
think because on the one hand as you
said with that the story about the
police that you highlighted at the start
of the show you know you do have people
saying oh we've just got to embrace this
term and you shouldn't be embarrassed
about it and they go out of the way so
you know being woke it just means well
just means be kind
it just means be nice and be alert to
racial injustice and and sexism and
homophobia and and just being a nice
person
but then on the other hand like you say
you know they don't actually own the
label very few of them actually own the
label directly
so they're kind of trying to reclaim it
from this
but i i think it is a good time to use
because i think it allows us to name
something
that a lot of people would rather we
didn't put a name to so you know all of
these different views i think the way i
see you know if you were to draw a venn
diagram between people who are kind of
really buying into critical race theory
and people who really buy into gender
ideology you know you see big overlaps
between these these different viewpoints
and and to me that's really what woke is
it's the overlaps between all of these
circles
and
they would rather the people who were
most woke would rather we didn't know
who they were would rather we didn't
kind of call them out for their um
authoritarian ideas
and so they don't want the label being
attached to them they're not keen on it
and i think actually being able to call
out that there's something going on here
um there's something that we should be
critical of because they're trying to
pass it off as oh it's just a question
of being kind it's just a question of
common sense whereas actually i think
there are some very very good reasons
for for questioning what's going on here
uh least of all because a lot of the
time it is actually quite racist i think
to get people to
always be thinking in terms of someone's
skin color
another problem that you have here is
that
moderate well-meaning well-balanced
well-educated people on the left that
want to genuinely make progress for
minority groups and groups that are
oppressed they now also get lumped in
from right-wing commentators anybody
that starts to move toward progressive
politics can kind of be smeared with the
same term you know it's the same as
anybody that's slightly conservative
being alt-right or a proto-fascist you
know that's the same dog whistle that
comes from both sides and you know
there's equivalent terms on both ways
and this low resolution thinking just
happens right people just aren't
bothered with nuance and they want to
smear people with a term but if i was
somebody that was on the moderate
well-meaning left i would be so pissed
at the people that are these screaming
social justice warrior wildos on the
internet like
i think you're actually seeing this
who's the guy that writes for the
guardian the the
um
jones thank you yeah i knew you had to
say just the guardian who have hundreds
of writers and you already knew who i
meant
owen jones to me
if i was on the left i would want to
denounce him as quickly as possible i'm
like yo you you are not making this
situation any better
not only is he
taking like ridiculous positions that
don't make any sense and making a fool
of himself
regularly but then also appears to
not really actually care that much and
as soon as somebody diverges from his
view of how the left and how progress
should be done he's very quick to turn
on them as well
yeah no absolutely and there's so many
examples like this you know where it or
you could look at people or you know you
can look at different ideas that come
forward as well so uh one new story that
was quite big in the uk at the weekend
with some um i think islington it had to
be islington didn't it council in in
london which is put out a a training
booklet for its nursery teachers as he's
saying that the babies start being
racist from the age of three months old
you know they become aware of different
skin colors and they start showing
preferences for different for kind of
the same skin color as their own from
the age of just three months and kind of
giving advice to nursery teachers on how
best to challenge this well you know
anybody with an ounce of common sense
knows that this is completely ridiculous
the idea of babies being
kind of born racist it becomes an almost
religious idea of original sin and the
nursery teacher a bit like nuns who ran
schools kind of in the olden days yeah
have to beat out this original sin of
racism from these three-month-old babies
but but the problem is you know i do
completely take your point i think this
is what makes it very difficult then for
for people who are kind of moderately
anti-racist or not i don't mean
moderately anti-racist you know god i'm
i'm i would consider myself to be
anti-racist i think we should we should
all be anti-racist but but what woke's
done is it's changed the definition of
of what it actually means to be
anti-racist so i've got this really
vivid memory i mean must be a good kind
of 20 30 years ago now but i think can
you remember if you remember you're
probably too young but what like the
bennett on adverts when bennett used to
do kind of yeah like really political um
but also quite shocking adverts as well
i i don't know if this was bennett and
maybe it was it was something that was
put out actually by one of these kind of
anti-racist organizations but but this
i'm absolutely convinced this was true
and well you know people can google it
afterwards and and i'm sure it will come
up on google images there was an advert
and it had um pictures of like maybe
five or six babies um all kind of
wrapped up in the blankets talking
little little like two months three
month old babies all wrapped up in in
blankets and just their faces and you
could see their faces with different
colors and it said at the top you know
there's one place in britain where
racism does not exist
and and do you know it it's true you
know babies are not racist babies were
not are not born
racist and the definition of racism that
i had when i was growing up was that
racism was discrimination plus power you
know it wasn't just a question of
discrimination it was a question of you
kind of having prejudices but also
having power to kind of put these
prejudices make these prejudices
meaningful it wasn't it wasn't just a
question of kind of
you know dislike personal
preferences or whatever it was being
able to make these make discriminatory
uh put discrimination into practice and
and the idea that a baby then was able
to do that was ridiculous but but what
woke has done is it's completely changed
the definition of racism on its heads of
racism is something that's not just in
institutions but that all of us have got
inside us uh you know that well when i
say all of us i mean white people that
white people are born with this um sense
of kind of inherent um
superiority uh that we've got this white
privilege
um
and that we kind of need to be educated
have have this kind of educated out of
us from the moment in which from the
moment from which we're born
and like say i think that makes it very
very difficult for the people who are
um just your kind of centrists or you
know you're kind of moderate campaigners
and activists because when the whole
notion of what it means to be an
anti-racist changes so fundamentally
it's it's like how do you then
differentiate yourself within that i
mean either you think babies are born
racist or you don't
and i i definitely don't
but but that doesn't mean to say i don't
think racism exists in some
circumstances it doesn't mean today i
don't think racism is a problem i
certainly doesn't mean to say it's not
something i think should be challenged
where it does exist but the more we
start pointing the finger at babies as
being the source of racism the danger is
you then actually fail to see the real
um racism when it stares you in the face
what's happened with the shift from
class to identity on the left
yeah i think that's a major major factor
this and this is again another reason
why i think it's so important that we
challenge woke politics so just that
phrase that i was using there in
discussing races white privilege it kind
of suggests that ideas around privilege
have been linked to skin color you know
which is completely
ridiculous for anybody who's grown up in
a working class community you know who's
struggling to make ends meet now you
know that privilege is not a question of
skin color
privilege is very much linked to social
class whereas i think because the left
in particular has really given up on
working-class people as not just given
up on them as a as a force for change
but actually now is very quick to
condemn working-class people yeah how do
you think that's happened
yeah i think it's something that's been
going on for a long time now i mean
probably since like the 1970s really as
far back as that and i think they look
at how people have voted in elections
for example like their own failure to be
elected uh other than obviously during
the blair era you know the labor party's
not been electorally very successful in
the uk
and rather than turning the spotlight
inwards and thinking well why are we not
appealing to the electorate what's
what's wrong with the policies that
we're putting forward what's wrong with
the ideas that we're putting forward
it's much easier to point the finger
outwards and say well obviously we're
brilliant um you lot are obviously thick
and ignorant and racist and sexist and
backward for not voting for us and i
think you see right like i said right
dating back from the 1970s 1980s the
left has just increasingly lost touch
with the working class i mean and and
through its own failures it's rather
than trying to think about you know what
what's wrong with what why are we not
offering something aspirational
something um that's exciting a positive
like really to me like the the sentiment
that i think all people share but but
working-class people in particular is
this desire that you want a better life
for yourself
if you have kids you want your kids to
have a better life than you had when you
were growing up you know you want the
best for your kids and to me that's a
really normal human instinct and and
like i said the less you have the more
you want your kids to have a better life
the more you want a better life for
yourself
but the left just seemed completely
incapable of tapping into that you know
too often that i mean if you look at the
way they've bought i know the right have
done this as well but the left so much
bought into kind of like
environmentalism
um the idea of of net zero you have
really gone big down that line and you
can't at the same time say to people you
know you've got to have less
and tap into the aspiration for people
to want a better life you know the two
things are fundamentally contradictory
but you look at i mean another thing
happened this weekend was jamie oliver
the celebrity chef uh doing big protest
outside downing street against the
government um
for the government's stopped
overturned its ban on supermarkets doing
buy one get one free deals on food and
jamie oliver you know is there kind of
like the revolutionary outraged that
poor people might be able to get food a
little bit cheaper
in the middle of a cost of living crisis
rather than the left actually saying yes
what's really important is that we do
make food cheaper instead you've got
this idea that you know well these
people they're so fat
they're so
not in control of their own lives
they're just going to go out there and
buy all this unhealthy food and cram
their faces full of fat and become obese
and unhealthy
when you've got that really contemptuous
view of the working class you you know
you're
really looking at them in disgust you
know
you're not selling something that people
actually want so i think the left then
having abandoned the working class in
disgust has looked to different identity
groups to provide them with the
constituency so it's much easier to
think instead of looking to working
class people you know let's let's try
and focus on black people or transgender
people or you know these different
identity groups as a way of kind of
trying to find some people you can still
appeal to and make out like you're a
really nice person in the process
peter the plebs are uprising we don't
know what to do
they're going to the supermarkets to buy
two rally jamie oliver we'll get him in
he'll come and fix it jamie get yourself
out there these poor people these fat
bastards let's go and get them sorted
yeah it is it is so bizarre cause
remembering that working class cuts
across the racial lines right so if you
help people that are working class or
underclass you're helping black white
asian in the uk as well a lot of
pakistani a lot of indian a lot of
bangladeshi and
okay
how's that not a better policy um
it does it just seems like a really
stupid way of trying to
of signaling virtue whilst not actually
doing anything that delivers it
the thing that surprises me is that the
the left and has really sort of stuck at
this point for so long because at least
in the uk and almost in the the last u.s
election you know sort of biden only
really pipped it to the post um in the
uk it was a complete landslide it was
obvious that the left's messaging didn't
resonate with the electorate and the
bottom line is your job in government
should be should be to actually make the
country better but in reality is to get
elected so it's kind of impressive that
you are sticking to a rhetoric and a
type of ideology that is so evidently
unsuccessful in the one thing that
you're sort of primarily here to do
you're sticking at that you're sticking
at this messaging which doesn't resonate
i mean losing places like ashington
which is not far away from where i mean
you were born and was this labor
stronghold you know pit village miners
no one would be able to understand what
the the accents of of the sort of
thickest people on there uh and you
think
how would that flip
right how would that flip to actually
become a conservative constituency and
the the finger gets pointed at these
people and they say
these sort of idiot backyard mining town
hicks you know these chavs in tracksuit
bottoms that don't know what's good for
them and that's the preachiness that you
see with the let's rally jamie oliver
let's get him out there he fat [ __ ]
everywhere like that's the same sort of
sense that i get and even if that's not
true right even if it is the case that
um
everybody that's putting forward these
sort of progressive policies that focus
on gender and race even if they are
coming from a good place that's not how
it's perceived
right so either
you your messaging is way off base and
your your um the shop window is kind of
a little bit ruined
or this is genuinely what you mean to do
and you're a perverse idiot
no absolutely i mean i think the truth
is a bit about for those things because
it's i mean i think one thing is you
know who who is the labour party are
trying to appeal to now and again i'm
saying the labour party but i do think
there's some strong elements of this in
the conservative party as well you know
i think they they worry far too much
about how something plays out on twitter
for example you know when you look at
somebody like jess phillips standing up
in parliament giving her
um gobby speeches you know you just get
the sense that they're far more bothered
about how many retweets and how many
likes they're going to get for recording
that or whether people are going to say
bad things about them on social media or
whether this is going to kind of appeal
to
their
friends essentially their their middle
class bubble will they get approval from
from their narrow
um social bubble and and you i mean i
think one thing that really
shows this is the case is again you know
i'm into my venn diagrams this evening
but if you look at kind of the people
who will make up the political
journalists the media class academics
politicians even the political class you
know there's so many kind of overlaps
between these i mean even look at kind
of
literal marriages between political
journalists and politicians and you know
who was best man at whose wedding the
kids go to the same school as each other
you know these people hang around on
sports days at their kids scores
barbecues at the weekend they live in
the same even in the same few streets in
london you know never mind um
anywhere bigger outside of that see they
create these kind of bubbles for
themselves and they become
interested then and how this plays out
in their bubble rather than how this
plays out with the people who are likely
to vote for them i mean brexit obviously
is the number one example of this um i
mean i'm absolutely convinced that
what's um lost the labour party to the
north is kiestarma you know as soon as
he became the pm you just saw you know
oh sorry as soon as he became the leader
of the labor party you just said this
guy is never ever ever gonna be voted as
pm because he was the architect behind
labour's decision to
um try and hold a second referendum to
try and overturn
the referendum result and really the
message that was sending out to
uh millions of voters in the northeast
of england and you know across the uk
really who voted leave was well your
vote counts for nothing you know we we
don't care how you voted we're going to
make you vote again we're going to look
for ways to overturn your vote we're
going to
use the legal system to try and get
around whatever what what you thought
you were voting for you were obviously
too thick you didn't know the
consequences we know better than you and
we're going to override it at any cost
whatsoever
and people don't forget these things you
know precisely because people are not
thick you know they they know that kia
stammer played this role they know what
was meant what he was meaning to do and
they know that he's never apologized for
that or never uh you know really changed
his mind on this
um so yeah i think i think the labour
party certainly under kierstarma have
really got a long way to go
how do you think that all of this
relates to sort of women and women's
rights i know that you've done
work on feminism and the relationship
between women and feminism in the past
how does all of this play into that
situation
yeah i think in a number of ways i mean
when i was writing about feminism five
years ago well i mean things have
changed a lot in a very very short space
of time so when i wrote my book women
versus feminism
never occurred to me to think that you
would need an introduction that was
actually about defining what is a woman
you know i just completely took it for
granted that feminism was about women
was concerned with women and everybody
knew what a woman was if i was writing
that book again today i think i would
need to start with chapter one page one
you know feminism is about women and we
have to say what a woman is um and i
think that means again another way in
which we've actually gone backward as a
society i don't know if you saw it but
uh it was in manchester uh not this
weekend just gone but the weekend before
um women were holding a protest around
the statue of emeline pankas was that
where posey parker went and spoke yeah
absolutely and you got um a transgender
activist in fully masked up balaclavas
or dressed in black kind of violently
stopping these women from going to stand
next to the statue of emily and pancaste
who is who's emmeline pankhurst why she
sorry oh so she was one of the key
suffragettes uh she was involved in
fighting for votes for women um which
obviously like goes without saying is
major major
um
step forward for women's rights you know
that these were kind of heroes that
she's somebody who would be a personal
hero of mine and changed the nature of
politics um you know gave by by giving
women the vote allowed women to
have their concerns dealt with in
parliament taken seriously you know
we wouldn't have had things like the
equal pay act um you know all the
important legislation that's enabled
sexual equality would not have happened
without the suffragettes and without um
women being able to have the vote and
yet then for these masked
men it seemed most of them were men um
to be standing there stopping
uh her women
now celebrating i mean to me it just
turns the clock back on women's rights
potentially a hundred years you know if
you're not allowed to say we want to
have single sex spaces for women you
know this is what it means to be a woman
with a when woman becomes this kind of
unsayable swear word almost you know you
you can't defend women's rights you're
left unable to do that and you know this
is
should be something that really really
worries us
um but prior to that though something
that really strikes me about feminism
that ties into something that you were
talking about earlier that i kind of
missed but i really wanted to come back
to when when you're saying about um the
importance of class and how if you
if campaigners did just focus on class
they would actually end up improving the
lives of a lot of black and minority
ethnic people because i think that's so
true and such a really really important
point because you look at a lot of the
time there is a correlation because of
historical disadvantage historical
discrimination you know patterns of
immigration that we've had into this
country going back over many many
decades where you know you look at the
kind of pakistani community around parts
of yorkshire for example really is very
economically deprived now you think if
you did just focus on working class
people you would raise up the living
standards the the job opportunities the
educational opportunities for people in
those communities whereas instead what
these work activists do which i think is
so terrible with their focus and
identity is it's almost like they take
those disadvantages the disadvantages
experienced by some women by some black
and minority ethnic people
and they kind of take those
disadvantages and they appropriate them
for themselves so they they look at kind
of what's a correlation you know um
black people might be more likely to be
in poverty or
uh you know women there might be a
gender pay gap but that's not for all
women it's not you know you look at the
women who work in the bbc for example as
presenters who have been bringing court
cases for equal pay you know those women
are hardly hard up you know they've got
six figure salaries they're kind of
doing all right thank you very much but
the way they kind of talk about the
gender pay gap you think that they were
the most disadvantaged people one
society what's the update on the gender
pay gap at the moment
well i mean it's very controversial i
mean how did you define gender
joking um
but
it depends i mean it's a
how how would you measure it and this is
the issue with it so if you take an
average pay gap and this is the one that
the campaigners always like to use
basically adding up all the money and by
men and dividing it by the number of men
compared to all the money and by women
dividing it by the number of women you
can get quite a big difference you can
get i mean between about 20 and 15
pay gap which is a lot lower his in
historical terms is lower than it's ever
been but of course that average figure
ignores a lot of facts like men and
women don't always choose to go into the
same jobs they don't always do the same
degrees or training courses and
particularly when women reach the age
when they start having children that's
the point at which you see quite big
differences that women might go
part-time at work or might drop out of
work altogether for a few years
and obviously the way campaigners have
it is that this is something which is
forced upon women by a kind of
prejudiced and discriminatory society
you know there may be an element of
truth in that because chuck has very
expensive so you end up making choices
you know who's earning the most money at
that point and then you make a choice
but what it ignores is any element of
women actually choosing you know it kind
of says that no woman
chooses that she wants to take a year
out a couple of years out when she has
children now i mean suddenly i did my
children are
grown up now you know they're a bit
older now but um
when i had two children kind of under
the age of three you know i did stop
work for a couple of years and then i
went back very part-time so clearly my
pay fell at that point you know clearly
if you don't work you don't get paid or
if you work for the time that's your
internalized patriarchal oppression that
you've now your stockholm syndrome is
coming back out of your mouth and
leaking into your career aspirations the
fact that you decided to play the game
that men had made for you because no
woman would choose to actually spend
their time at home looking after their
children because two three-year-old
children and spending the only time that
you're ever going to get with them which
now you can't because they're fully
grown up
there's no reason that you would want to
do that instead of
putting in numbers onto a keyboard or
writing articles for some company that
you don't take any of the money home for
you know
you're right clearly i know it was a
choice that i made and i think
i think that the thing is you
feminism almost pushes you into this
narrative where it becomes easier to
present yourself as a victim it became a
lot more socially acceptable i know in
my own circumstances to say oh well the
reason why i'm doing this is because the
child care is so expensive and you know
it's very difficult for times and
everything and
actually
just owning the choice and just saying
you know i've chosen to do this is is
kind of made very difficult for you
celebrating
celebrating motherhood seems like
such an uncool and unpopular thing to do
and the only reason that any woman would
choose it is because of their
internalized patriarchal oppression um
and that sucks
this discussion i was at the
international fitness summit last year
right so you've got it was 60 40 girls
to guys maybe even more maybe 70 30
goals to guys and they were talking
about the fact that um women in the
fitness industry there's still sort of a
objectification of how they look of the
way that they're presented i was looking
around the room and i said well there's
we're two to one outnumbered here with
girls the girls are putting their hands
up and they're making insane amounts of
money and why is it that women are being
paid this and so on and so forth one of
the guys just put his hand up and said
well what about women that actually want
to be mothers you're saying that it
shouldn't be the case that women have to
take time off that there should be more
i think it's australia that has uh a way
that you can alter the um
uh
men's and woman's time away from work
and you can kind of share it overall he
said well hang on what what if you just
want that what if that's something that
you're looking forward to
remembering as well that in the same
breath
people will complain about the fact that
it's almost impossible to raise a child
on a one
parent income so that both parents
actually do need to work and yet if you
have one parent that chooses not to work
that's somehow seen as making a
sub-optimal decision because of
internalized patriarchy
no absolutely and again you know i think
a lot of these decisions are quite
class-based as well and that's not given
credit for because
ultimately if your job is going to sit
in a nice office yeah you're a nice warm
driver you sit in front of a laptop you
can mess about on social media for a
good part of the day you've got coffee
on demand and
interesting colleagues that you can
gossip to whenever you like
actually doing that in in preference to
being at home struggling with toddlers i
mean it's not easy um i've got to be
honest i is is probably preferable you
know and you and also you've got that
status of saying you're going out to
your busy job whereas if your job is
kind of being a carer physically
demanding
low paid working in a supermarket long
antisocial hours you are going to have
more status more control over your life
by by being a mum um but again what
feminism can do often is look down on
working-class women who've made that
decision you know for
rather than kind of looking at why
people have made this decision it just
kind of comes across as very snobby that
they've made the wrong decision as a
bloke as well i really love the idea of
being able to say i've spent most of my
twenties and so far most of my 30s as
well working building up businesses
accumulating wealth investing really
really smartly i didn't haven't updated
my car for seven years i really like the
idea of being able to give the gift to
my future wife that look if you want to
take time away from work for
three five years that's fine
i'll go do my thing i still want to
spend as much time with the kids as
possible but i've constructed a life
that facilitates my future wife and the
mother of my children to be able to go
and do that
and then for me to be told that that's
what
me oppressing or restricting the career
opportunity of my i mean my future wife
is going to be incredibly well balanced
so this isn't going to be a problem but
my point being that i have a bunch of
friends a bunch of guy friends who are
older than me who have done this and
they're so proud right that's such a
sense of fatherly
protector provider presider um pride for
them right like it feels and i can't
think of anything that would be better
than that than coming home and knowing
that all of the hard work that you've
put in not just now not right now but
that you did from the degree university
from all of the hours of applying to
jobs or starting your own thing or
uncertainty or insecurity or all of that
stuff has led you to the point now where
you can create a family life which is
like the one that everybody says
you they want it to be we want it to be
like the 60s and the 70s where you could
uh achieve on a single parent
household's income you go okay if i've
worked really really hard and managed to
get myself into a fortunate position
where i can do that
why wouldn't i oh right that's because
it kind of highlights that not
everybody's allowed to do this and
there's disparities in inequality
but i think what's really important in
what you've just said that you know
right at the beginning when you're
saying you know you would like to be
able to make this as an offer you know
you're talking about the conversation
you would have with some your
poor future and my future wife you know
but that's the key thing for me you know
you're not saying and you must stay at
home i'm ordering you to stay at home
you're talking about a dialogue you're
talking about a conversation that may
not take place at some point in the
future but to me that is like how the
vast majority of people i know
run their lives you know it's a
relationship it's a partnership it's not
one person saying you must do this and
another person's saying i
will only do this you know it's a
negotiation
and obviously everybody's making these
negotiations in different circumstances
in different contexts but i think the
problem with a lot of feminism and
identity politics more broadly to come
back to the book is it pitches people
against each other it suggests that you
know what's good for men is bad for
women and the other way around you know
that where we're kind of locked into
some competition one against the other
that you know if i want to get a job
i've kind of got to get one over on my
husband or he's constantly trying to get
one over on me
and actually that's not the way it is in
real life at all you know you've got
families together struggling through
often you know trying to work out how to
bring up children how to make ends meet
financially but they're doing this as a
conversation in partnership with each
other
and and not as a competition i like the
idea of thinking about the fact that not
all people are in a position where the
most important thing in their life or
their sense of purpose actually comes
from their career you know that's
for me right now that is the thing that
i have but
you you're totally correct for a ton of
working-class people what is it uh
70 percent of people
are
uh
not engaged with their job and 15
percent of people are actively
disengaged that's 85 percent of people
are either unengaged or actively
disengaged with the work that they do so
you're talking about only 15 percent of
people and i think this is across men
and women who actually really care and
love the work that they do and you go
okay so you're going to deny this person
the ability to take something which may
give them way more fulfillment because
of an arbitrary decision that you've
made about the fact that raising
children is somehow seen as lesser and
also talking about the the um like
adversarial
nature that is seen now from any
identity versus any other identity it
seems to me that women are fighting a
war on two fronts they're fighting one
against what it means to be a woman and
then against real and imagined uh
patriarchal oppression and systemic and
this still is and this is the thing this
i i always get to this when i'm having
this conversation
it's so easy to tumble into work bashing
and this ridiculousness that's coming
from the left and progressives with blue
hair screaming on the street and
gluing themselves to the road and stuff
like that
and there's always a bit in the back of
my mind where i go all of the sympathy
that should be focused toward people
that really really need it here is being
forgotten because there are these very
loud idiots in front of them that is
super easy to mark and i i
have to constantly check myself i really
dislike
the periods in which i find myself
watching too much right wing content if
i find myself watching too much
reactionary right-wing stuff
it always makes me feel it's like icky
it makes me feel a bit icky it makes me
feel
reactionary adversarial defensive
um
uncompassionate all of these things
no i agree completely i really really
agree with you but you know i
i actually blame the work left for that
because i think the more you get the
message to see um racism sexism
homophobia
transphobia everywhere you know in every
little interaction to go back to the
babies we were talking about earlier you
know when when we're told that these
things are everywhere it kind of becomes
nowhere you know and and you look at
um
then then you you kind of
like say when it when it's everywhere
you you kind of become blind to the real
instances that's one thing but i think
the other thing is it it creates
particularly and i'm going to say
perhaps something sexist now but i think
perhaps particularly in young men and
i'm talking kind of teens early 20s you
know whether it's like a shock value a
bit like kind of farting loudly in the
library or you know saying [ __ ] off to
your mum for the first time or something
like that you know where you i feel like
you're living in this quite oppressive
culture where you've got to watch what
you say constantly you know you you
you've you're being monitored all the
time and so kind of going to quite an
extreme anti-woke position
becomes a form of rebellion it actually
becomes a bit of a kind of shock value
attractive thing to do and i don't agree
with that and i don't think it's helpful
politically but at the same time i can
kind of get why they do this so if you
look at
students in universities for example i
think universities is unfortunately
nowadays some of the most censorious
places where you've not just got the
kind of
like you say the kind of blue head
people
um going around kind of banning speakers
or getting petitions to stop people
coming onto campus but then you get the
reaction oh but you've also got this
just a very strong sense of what you can
and can't say you know even when it's
not protest there's this sense that some
views are just not to be said in a
seminar room or or you know on on
university
um so then you look at students who kind
of want to protest against this and so
they they think you know right who's the
most
radical controversial person we can
invite to come and speak you know let's
go
let's resurrect milo yiannopoulos and
bring him back to no one's seen him for
five years but we'll bring him back to
have him on campus yeah i know what you
mean i mean that's just troll mentality
overall right that's the sort of troll
sphere of the internet people saying
that which is unacceptable or
unbelievable and this has been the case
ever since um like was it steak and
cheese.com that was people who would be
losing fingers in videos and you know
all of the stuff that would be forwarded
around on blackberry messenger a decade
and a half ago and it's just the new
version of that but because the overtone
windows come in so much your ability to
step outside of it has become easier and
easier um
i don't know i think it's
it really is it makes me uncomfortable
to think about the fact that virtuous
social justice like genuine social
justice campaigns have been hijacked
weaponized and then uh caricatured by
people that have seen something that
they think they can kick around as a
convenient political football and
i would be i
i would be very very pissed if i was
somebody on the moderate left and
i don't i don't know what the solution
is for that no i mean i think one thing
is just to always ask you know who's
benefiting from this you know whatever
the particular campaign might be
who's gaining from this so you look at
so much of the kind of critical race
theory training that goes on for example
well you've got some people particularly
in the u.s but to a less extent in the
uk as well who are really raking it in
you know on off the back of say
diversity training programs in the
workplace um
who you know i would describe as kind of
race entrepreneurs who
claim to have some special insight that
other people lack and like so i think i
think the problem is it it does become
genuinely i think you're really
touching upon something here because i i
think it does become genuinely very very
difficult then to be a kind of
political moderate in this in this
climate i mean it goes back to what
we're saying earlier about the way even
being an anti-racist to me this is why
i'm so opposed to wow because
to me it's just racism rehabilitated to
me that the whole kind of
um debate around transgender is sexism
rehabilitated you know it's all the
old-fashioned prejudices the that all my
kind of childhood and youth you know um
we were talking earlier about stockton
sixth form college you know where where
we both went to at very very different
times but you know it was at stockton
sixth form college i picked up a leaflet
one day um from some people outside the
gates there was the youth rights
campaign turned out to be the a kind of
junior wing of militant um very kind of
big in the labor party in the kind of
90s and early 90s late 80s early 90s and
from there you know went to the
socialist worker party
um
revolutionary communist party was where
i ended up you know my political
background
very very much on the left but it's like
every principle that i had that was a
left-wing principle about the importance
of free speech for example about the
importance of transcending race i
believe that there's one race the human
race about the ability about the idea
that you you didn't buy into gender
stereotypes you know women didn't have
to wear pink dresses but to be a
stereotypical kind of feminine woman you
know you could dress how you liked but
still be a woman it just seems like all
those really backward ideas that i was
challenging when i was young and
revolutionary and and left-wing have
have become completely flipped 360
degrees they now mean the absolute
fundamental opposite to what they did
25-30 years ago and i think that makes
it really difficult for people who want
to campaign genuinely for social justice
nowadays
rehabilitated racism and sexism
masquerading as compassion
that's it like that's exactly what's
happening um
do you think that there's a little bit
of a moral panic on the right as well
about this so i look at the cultural
commentators the people that are
crushing it on youtube the people the
sort of stories that we see and i
understand how it's sort of red meat for
the mob if you have another ridiculous
wokey headline about something that's
insane
but how much is this actually capturing
the things that we really care about
like it doesn't seem to me
that real world change that affects
actual people appears to be happening
and i think that a lot of my moderate
friends on the left would say look
the moral panic that you see that's loud
from the blue hairy people on the left
is equivalently being reacted to by the
people on the right that they're saying
that all of these policies around woke
and transgenderism and racism and sexism
and stuff like that they're not actually
trickling down to sort of grow any corn
in anywhere that's real it just exists
kind of um like arbitrarily or
culturally within media and within some
higher circles of academia but it's
never actually hitting anything do you
think that there's a moral panic on the
right about this stuff too
oh yeah i kind of think both the things
that you've said though like two
different things are actually both true
which is probably not helpful so i'll
tease out what i mean by that so i do
think there is a danger of moral panic
and clearly a lot of people nowadays as
we were talking earlier are into the
social media clicks and i think that's
definitely a thing on the right as much
as on the left and um i mean i know i
run my own website keo a little think
tank and i know if i publish something
with trans or woke in the
uh headline you know the number of hits
it will get will go through the roof and
i do consciously round myself in because
i think you know i can't just go around
kind of writing about trans or woke
every week it would be an easy thing to
fall into and and if you were addicted
just to getting those clicks then you
could do that you know that's what you
would do and it's kind of a cheap thrill
if you like it becomes uh a way of of
kind of appearing to have a lot of
bravado um in a way that i think i agree
with you is unhelpful
but you know at the same time
just when i every time i say to myself
you know now calm down don't get carried
away don't inflame moral panics you open
the newspaper and there's some story
like again exactly the one that you
kicked off with you know about the
police having this training being told
to embrace the world woke or you just
think oh for god's sake you know
could we not just stick on the fighting
crime [ __ ] you know why do you have to
go down this why do you have to provide
the
um fodder for the next headline writer
to come along and cry out you know the
police awoke
of course people are going to say the
police awoke if you're there saying as
the police trainer oh we really want our
officers to embrace the word work you
know why provide this um
poor fuel on the fire if you like for
the extremists does it ever escalating
game of tit for tat that's going on here
and i don't know how you get this to
stop right i noticed this
two two years ago i did this really
short video it's about three minutes
long and it was looking at um
would you have had the reaction of blm
and stuff had charlottesville not happen
then blm would you have had january 6
then january 6th with whatever and you
just see this constant sense that
because a thing was done we are
justified to do the same thing in the
opposite direction and this exactly
occurs online where
the right-wing commentators they feel
justified because they say look here is
a ridiculous story about the police
that's going on if we don't
push back against this then
we're seceding ground to people who are
trying to take over the lexicon or
they're trying to take over institutions
or academia so this is the weapon that
we have to go back
back to them and you go okay well who's
the first mover here because is it that
you know chicken and egg is it the fault
of the news stories is it the fault of
the policy is it the fault of the
right-wing commentators for actually
promulgating that i mean we saw this
with jordan peterson with the sports
illustrated cover the most number of
clicks that sports illustrate it's ever
got probably came from the fact that he
highlighted it so you go okay so
who's at fault here is it the fault of
the people that put the policy out is it
the fault of the people that bring more
attention to it by pushing back would it
be better to not push back all of these
questions i think are really interesting
but to me it doesn't
it it's definitely not getting us
anywhere it's one of the reasons why
conservatism generally just isn't very
exciting i don't know why as a young
person you would be enthralled by
conservatism at the moment because you
go what are you what are you proposing
when was the last time you actually
proposed anything that wasn't you
playing defense it's permanently the
right playing defense and the ref the
left proposes left proposes something
crazy online
policy transgender new words new lexicon
whatever and then the right plays
defense against it
no one's making progress here
no completely um i mean i i
i think
one way to look at this though is to ask
who really has the power in our society
you know
what do the people who
hold the most powerful positions what do
they think
and
you know i think
it is the case to for me that woke ideas
have gained ground within schools within
universities within the civil service
you know that they are the powerful
people nowadays they are the
um the source of influence in society
not just kind of because it's where most
of the middle class are at kind of i or
lots of the middle class ideologically
but they're actually the people who
really
wield power but the way they do it is is
very discreet you know and they try to
because of the victim status thing that
we were talking about earlier they tried
to deny the power that they possess you
know they will claim to actually be
victims not to be powerful
but i think what that means then is that
when they engage in a particular act for
example a cultural act for example
renaming a street renaming a school
removing a statue
contextualizing a statue or
taking the national anthem or whatever
it is out of the last night of the proms
you know that for them is just like a
neutral common sense just a kind of
under the radar
progress progressive thing to do
and
then when there's a reaction to it
because you're absolutely right you know
there is always a reaction to these
things
they then
point the finger and say you're starting
a culture war you know how dare you
insist that this statue stays in place
how dare you insist that we maintain
real britannia you know or or continue
to fly for union jack you you're
starting a culture war
well they only talk about culture wars
when it stops going their way you know
if they can do these things under the
radar if they can just give it a veneer
of common sense you know why wouldn't
you um stop flying the union jack why
wouldn't you remove this statue then
then they they would much rather do that
without anybody challenging or
questioning what they're doing and they
only call cultural when they get
challenges to that what would you say to
the people that
argue
those are not big important
uh decisions that yes maybe this might
be something that's happening and yet it
might be a little bit silly but in the
grand scheme of things that doesn't
matter and this proves that there is a
moral panic on the right about stuff
that's going on on the left
you see i i think these things do matter
and they don't that not just because
like i
don't think the union jack's like the
most amazing thing ever i don't know the
words to real britannia you know i'd
struggle beyond the first few lines of
god save the queen or whatever it is you
know i don't think these things are
important in their own terms but i think
i think the debates are very very
important because
particularly with the cost of living
crisis you know spiraling inflation
there are a lot of people who are saying
you know well now we'll have the time to
get back to real politics this is what's
really important to people if they don't
have enough money to heat their houses
put food on the table for their kids at
the end of the month you know this is
when real politics starts to um dig in
and we'll forget all about statues and
rule britannia and flags we'll get back
to the real stuff but the problem is you
know you you can't do that when all
these cultural battles are still what's
dominating politics because in order to
actually as we were saying earlier make
the case for people having more money in
their pockets
you can only do that when you've got a
strong powerful working-class voice you
know when you've got people
in communities in the northeast you know
who are not in your london bubble
getting their views heard about what
they want how they want to run their
lives what's important to them when
you've got a position where you in when
you're in a situation where
all the cultural values of working-class
people are being completely trashed at
every available opportunity and that
really means trashing working-class
people themselves
you can't then turn around and say
oh but you know
economically what what they're going to
get a few crumbs off the table a bit of
charity or we'll make a few more
donations to the food bank
actually you know that's not what
working-class people want they want to
be able to earn money fair day's wage
for a fair day's work you know they
don't want pity they don't want charity
they don't want food banks but but once
you've got this contempt this disdain
for the culture of the working class all
you're ever going to get is at very very
best pity and and to me pity is only one
small step from contempt
i think you're wrong i think that what
the working-class people really want is
for office aircon to no longer be sexist
to women i found this article in
newsweek that said a study on office
temperature complaints has suggested
that women are less likely to be
comfortable with their workplace
temperature than men are did you see
this i have seen it uh it found that a
phenomenon dubbed over cooling during
the summer in which air conditioning
systems cool down more rooms more than
is necessary may lead to women in
particular feeling uncomfortable the
study concluded there is a need to
rethink the approach to air conditioning
office buildings as a result of its
finding the us study involved data from
lots of people the tweets were limited
to the us and said the study alone found
that 38 percent of people who said they
were dissatisfied with office
temperature 64 of them were women so
you've got disproportionate office cond
air conditioning offices this is the
real cold face of the issues that we're
coming up against well the good news is
we've got the perfect solution to this
uh we just don't have people working in
offices anymore the middle classes now
work from home or work from home
whenever they feel like it and want to
and i think there's a growing class
divide now um you know given that we've
been talking about class here um there's
a grand class divide between the middle
class people who can choose to
work wherever they can sit with their
laptop you know they can put the washing
on be there when the children get home
from school answer the door to the
amazon deliveries um you know that
they've got can create this really
comfortable life for themselves saving
money on commuting saving money on the
the cups of coffee
whereas you've got a working class who
actually still needs to leave a house to
go to work um who actually if you know
again to use it
examples chosen at random of working in
a care home working in a supermarket
working as a delivery driver you know
you you can't do those things working
from home that's the bottom line but but
what's really interesting i think is how
the labour party is on the side of the
working from home people it's on the
side of the laptop classes the labour
party's there talking about the
importance of quality of life and how we
mustn't rush people back to the offices
um absolutely scathing of the fact that
jacob reese mogg has gone round leaving
notes on people's desks saying you
should get back to the office i mean
sold the fact that people you know
waiting weeks and weeks for a passport
missing holidays missing funerals of
relatives abroad um people who are
wanting to work as truck drivers can't
get the paperwork signed off can't get
the
driving licenses that they require you
know
i think we've created this really i
think the whole kind of covered and
pandemic experience the past two years
has massively exacerbated the class
divide but it's also really shown us
where the allegiances of the labor party
are nowadays and they're not with
working-class people they're with the
laptop people and and they're using woke
as a way of kind of covering up for this
they're using woke to pretend that
they're still virtuous and on the side
of the victim and really like say
they're on the side of the
elite
joanna williams ladies and gentlemen uh
if people want to keep up to date with
the stuff that you do where should they
go
uh well i'm on twitter at joewilliams293
and i write a weekly column for spiked
uh so definitely check out spiked every
day but you'll find me there at least
once a week thanks joe i appreciate you
pleasure real pleasure uh you know
you've really put me on the spot this
evening but in a very very good way
thank you what's happening people thank
you very much for tuning in if you
enjoyed that episode then press here for
a selection of the best clips from the
podcast over the last few weeks and
don't forget to subscribe
peace
you